why hello there hey what's up guys my
name is asiana welcome back to
another hazel devlog
it's been so long since the last one and
a lot of you probably think that i have
just
either abandoned hazel or i've just gone
on some holiday and i've just forgotten
about all of you but the truth is i've
actually just been working really hard
and sometimes when i
when i am working on a difficult project
i kind of tend to forget to make videos
or i don't feel like making videos
and instead i i tend to focus on the
programming and focus on the actual
work now that's not really like
every time i look back at this i don't
really like this and i think that it
would probably be
a lot better for me instead of like
going down this huge rabbit hole of just
you know depression basically trying to
fix certain problems instead of all of
that it's probably just better to just
sit down
and fill you guys in with what's
actually happening and this is basically
what this video
is so um i'm going to show i'm going to
be showing some stuff that isn't really
completed in hazeldev yet uh it's very
much work in progress i'm just going to
kind of talk to you
about what it is that i have been
working on and
uh you know various problems that i've
kind of encountered on the way
so first of all what have we been
working on um
in hazel there for like the last like
couple months so first of all
um you know when i say hazel dev i'm
referring to like the patreon version of
hazel like
my version of hazel the game engine
series is
something else and the hazel that we're
building in the game engine series is
kind of like a
you know it's going to be leading up
it's going to be getting into the stuff
that's in hazeldev later on but hazeldov
is kind of like my version of the engine
that i'm working on um along with a few
like amazing contributors as well who
are helping me out so
that's what hazel davis i'm not really
talking about the game engine series
game ninja series is going great um
i'm working on like a material system
for that and like figure figuring out
all the shader stuff i've been live
streaming on twitch tv slash the journal
a lot working on both the game engine
series and hazel dev
um but specifically hazel dev the thing
that we're working on at the moment is
basically supporting two rendering apis
opengl and vulkan so opengl is still
something that i want to support
um because certain devices uh
don't like older devices may not support
vulkan
um but also because i think that opengl
is a really nice kind of
api for anyone learning graphics
programming it's still something that i
recommend as
the kind of the the graphics api you
should start with if you're just
learning
about graphics programming because
instead of spending all of your time
you know trying to figure out all the
code you need to for example generate
mipmaps in
in vulkan you can just write gl gen
mipmaps
or glgen texture mipmaps in opengl and
you're done it's one line
right so my point being that instead of
focusing on the actual api
you focus a lot more on the theory of
actual graphics programming you write
shaders you write
you know the code that you need like the
actual
the actual graphics programming itself
and not the api
is where you spend most of your time in
opengl you decide how to render things
what techniques to use what shaders to
use that kind of stuff
whereas vulcan's more like low level and
more about like the driver and
you know memory access and memory
control synchronization that kind of
stuff so i still really like opengl and
i still think it's a great api to have
um especially in a series that is very
much
kind of you know supposed to be
for educational purposes and then
hazeldev being an engine that kind of
takes that way further so i am keeping
opengl for the time being
uh so anyway but adding vulcan um
first of all vulcan right um
lots of people uh always talk about how
hard vulcan is and
the thing is uh yeah it's it's a lot
more verbose it's a much lower level
a lower level api it's supposed to be
more kind of you know about the
controlling exactly what the driver is
doing rather than running you know one
line of code and then having the driver
figure stuff out
on its own that you don't even have any
awareness about so it is supposed to be
like that i haven't found that part too
difficult to be honest
i have been exposed to vulcan for
probably like since like
i don't know five years ago or so i
remember back when i worked at ea
before vulcan was even out you know um
nvidia would like send us drivers
and we would basically test you know
that on like
um you know we would kind of integrate
vulcan into our engine and then
run that on like android devices and
then watch them reboot when the driver
crashed and all that all that fun times
but
um i i guess i'm kind of used to vulcan
and i don't think that part is too
is too difficult especially because um
the validation of falcon is a lot better
than opengl still not as good as like
directx
um it's not as mature as directx either
uh so that's kind of to be expected but
the tools and the and the
um and the debugging kind of the
validation
is definitely a step up so in general
vulcan has actually been a
a decent experience for me i don't think
that it's been too difficult but there
are still a lot of kind of
um difficult problems to solve when it
comes to first of all making
a kind of api independent
renderer and an api independent
rendering api because one of my goals
with hazel
is not just to kind of have you know oh
here's a version of hazel that uses
opengl here's a version of hazel that
uses vulcan
no what i want is i want to be able to
actually create a kind of
api independent renderer api
lots of api wording here but basically
what i want to do is create like a
um a render api that is completely
abstracted away from the back end that
it's using whether that be vulcan or
opengl
or directx maybe in the future that kind
of stuff right so instead of actually
kind of
being uh very tightly coupled to the
render api you should still be able to
like in an abstract way basically
set up like all of your textures buffers
you know shaders uh pipelines um
render passes that kind of stuff uh and
then
um you know in behind the scenes that
will
translate into opengl calls if you're
running hazel with opengl
or vulcan calls if you're running it
with vulkan so that way you can actually
actually you know write your own
renderer instead of having to even use
hazel so and
you can do that in a very very kind of
cross uh you know api independent way
we'll say
so um because of that as well you know
everything has to be kind of this api
has to be designed in a way that works
with everything
that can be difficult at times um but
then the other thing is
you know for example like the shaders we
use the shaders we write in velcro cell
and then that gets compiled it gets
cross compiled into like opengl
compliant glsell and then we use that
with spur v
as binary shaders for opengl and for
vulcan so like the shaders are the same
um which is good as well and then if we
use dry attacks in the future they'll
probably also be written in a single
language
um and then cross compiled into
everything else so the general weight
there like everything seems to work and
everything seems to be
uh not too bad but there are still kind
of edge cases and
and certain situations where i do wish
that like vulcan would be
better at um validation and at kind of
uh debug ability we'll say because
sometimes the driver will crash
and it won't tell you why and you'll
have nothing to go on and that's kind of
where i'm at right now
um and it happens different it happens
on different drivers it happens at
different times it can happen
um you know on my desktop for example
with a 1080 ti
it happened i've seen it happen like
once in the last month
but then like on my laptop with like an
rtx 2060
you know what happens one in every 10
runs so if i just
keep running hazel it will the driver
will crash at some point
which in vulcan is kind of like a device
device loss kind of error
and then open jail sometimes will crash
as well randomly um and then
for some people it's like um they run it
and it's
like a hundred percent chance of it
crashing so that there are certain
things that are very difficult to kind
of debug and i do wish the falcon would
be better
um better in that sense but um the other
thing that i wanted to say is that uh
the way that i've designed this as well
is that the api kind of switching
the api like which api you decide to use
when you actually run hazel that's a
runtime kind of decision as well
so you don't need to compile hazel with
opengl or
compile hazel with vulkan it's
actually like right before you basically
create the context and right before you
create the window
you can specify if you want vulcan or
opengl just in the simplest code so it
can be a completely programmatic
decision
and that's kind of cool because it means
that you know you could
restart in a different api or you could
change apis i guess theoretically while
you're running you might have to like
recreate the window
or or recreate the context but you can
keep everything else in memory you don't
need to
re-kind of you know just completely
rerun the whole application um
and you can also on startup read like
some configuration file or
generate a random number and if it's
even then
vulkan will be used i mean you could
really do anything which is kind of cool
i think
but um anyway let me show you where i'm
at um this is again as i mentioned it's
gonna be a pretty chill video
so let's just run hazel and i'll kind of
give you guys a bit of a tour
so the crash um happens a lot of the
time
when environment maps are being used so
the way that we create environment maps
is basically we read in like a
an hdr equirectangular map um
and then we uh there's so many videos
i've been wanting to make on hazel about
all this kind of architecture stuff let
me know let me know
what you guys are interested in i can
because there's a lot of render api kind
of design and architecture that i could
talk about as well as like this
environment
map stuff there's something that you
that i ever mentioned that you guys want
more information about just drop a
comment
and uh and maybe i'll see that comment
maybe i'll be like i'll be super
inspired to like make a video and be
like okay that's it i'm making a video
on that
but um so uh environment maps at
rectangular they get converted into cube
maps they then get filtered
using um a really nice kind of filtering
algorithm so that like
the lower mips basically aren't just
generated by you know linearly
interpolating but they're actually kind
of
um you know sampled in like a very nice
kind of blurry fashion that just makes
it
buttery smooth when you actually down
sample them and then also we generate an
irradiance texture as well so we have
three
compute shaders that run to create all
of those maps and so we wind up with two
texture cubes or two cube maps um uh
which have been properly filtered as
well for all of their maps and that's
how we use environment maps but
unfortunately it's a little crashy
um and that's kind of what i'm talking
about and so what what will happen with
falcon is welcome will give me
like a what is it like yeah a vk error
device lost
um which basically means the driver has
crashed and no other validation
so first of all if there are any like
developers watching this who have had
experience with this
if you have any advice for debugging
this um
please let me know i have actually been
using the whole like
nvidia checkpoint stuff so
um nvidia actually have a little
extension that you can use for
uh these kind of diagnostic checkpoints
that you can literally
litter about in your code and i've tried
using them
and then retrieving them later and
seeing but i don't know it just kind of
it's supposed to kind of give you an
idea of where the crash is happening but
it doesn't really give you much more
than that so i have tried that
hasn't been that helpful in my
experience maybe i just haven't
tried hard enough but um basically the
way that i got around this crash which
is interesting because it's a bit of a
creative solution it's not really a
solution i haven't solved it yet
but um the problem is that there's a lot
more in this engine than just
graphics and rendering and you know for
example we have a new person
i'm kind of working on the hazel team
now who's going to be doing the audio
stuff
for hazel so like you know um all of the
audio programming basically so that we
can have
you know 3d audio and well anything you
do with audio basically all the tools we
need as well
um and that obviously has nothing to do
with environment maps and
if hazel is so unstable that it just
crashes randomly um
that person might be like okay whatever
i don't care that your cube maps don't
work
i need the engine not to crash and so a
lot of the time when you're working in a
team
um you know it's important to obviously
consider the fact that
just because one thing might not work
doesn't mean the whole
system doesn't work and so what i did
was on startup
i mean i made this little uh with this
kind of little modal
um dialogue here that basically just
um says that environment maps are kind
of disabled by default
uh because they're a little unstable in
certain gpu drivers and then there's an
option to enable them so we can enable
them because it probably won't crash
um and so if we were to for example like
create a skylight and then go into like
the environment
um panel down here and just grab like
this one i'm running a debug build so
this will actually take a little bit of
time
to uh load it because it does have to
run a little computer here to see this
will work right
and so we have our environment map and
obviously if we like create like um
we've actually got this objects panel
now if we create like a sphere and a
plane
you know or whatever um let's maybe
select the plane make it a bit bigger
um you know then of course you can see
that we are actually using that
environment map
this weird little bright spot by the way
in the middle that
i just noticed which is a bit uh i think
that's been there for a while actually
probably some shader bug anyway um
and uh oh yeah and also um you know we
can add a directional light see shadows
are working
so this is actually running vulcan by
the way i didn't really point that out
but
this is running in in vulcan at the
moment and i can actually
uh go to file and then restart with
opengl this is something i just added
and then it will actually relaunch it in
opengl and um
you should see again debug builds it's a
little slow um if i enable this as well
we're now we're now running in opengl
and of course it looks the same
um i think i've got vsync enabled so the
frame time
might be kind of different but um
you know if i add that skylight back and
recreate that scene
you should see that it kind of should
work the same way
so we can kind of run them of course in
both apis and that's basically the big
change here
that's kind of you know for if this is a
devlog right
so since the last episode which i think
was about
was it really about 3d physics is that
the last thing i showed or like the
the first person camera controller i
think so since then this is kind of what
i've been working on and then peter for
example
peter has been working on um there are
other people on the hazel team
um which i need to uh i really need to
make a little contributors thing so that
we can actually list everyone who's
who's contributed but um peter has been
working on like this
asset system basically with all his
asset panels that's kind of his doing
um and then we've got we've got some
other really exciting stuff in the works
that i will reveal
as it gets kind of integrated but uh you
know there's been other stuff going on
um it's just that i've been kind of i've
had my head in this vulcan issue
and i haven't i've kind of been
neglecting to uh
to make devlogs which is not good so i
accept that that's not good anyway we
can leave them off
and if we leave them off if we load a
scene that has them um
pretty much everything has them to be
honest i can load this shadow test scene
um this had this does have a skylight
but then also like you know today for
example
a day in the life of churno um i spent
about 15 minutes being like okay
today is going to be the day that i
solved this and then i got bored
and so i'm like wouldn't it be nice if
we didn't even use cube maps why don't
we have some kind of dynamic sky model
and so i added that and so
uh we actually have this option for
dynamic sky here which i can enable
and then if i kind of change some of
these parameters then you can see that
we actually have a skype that's been
created um this is like the paretham
skype
model um it's pretty popular um
and uh you know we can basically change
the time of day
uh and that's a little bright there
let's
kind of change some of these settings um
so we can change and this has nothing to
do with directional light so the shadow
and stuff will complete completely not
related to
like the sun position but um yeah we can
like change this
you know change the time of day change
the kind of um
position here or whatever this is kind
of like the brightness
um and yeah we have this like
essentially the sun that moves around
and the time of day is linked to
um the kind of well the the light kind
of style is linked to
the uh inclination of the sun and like
the position and
what the time of day is and all that
which is pretty cool um so that's like
you know that's kind of what i
a lot of the times what i end up doing i
end up being just getting getting
distracted and being like oh look a
shiny thing i'll just add that into the
engine
um which is kind of like you know it's a
bit annoying um in a way because
maybe i should be solving this problem
but on the other hand i feel like it's
important to
uh you know somewhat kind of i guess you
know reward yourself almost at times
with like you know uh giving yourself a
bit of a break
and letting yourself do something
creative because solving a
driver crash is not really
that creative i won't say it's
completely not creative i mean there
have been some creative things i've
tried
but it's not as creative as you know
doing something like this sky
so i think my point with this is that
even though i haven't solved this driver
problem just yet i think it's really
important
to take a break and to take a deep
breath and
also to uh be aware of the fact that
sometimes even when it seems like
whatever you're working on is never
going to have a solution
it probably is and if you look back at
your own life and you look at
situations in which you know you've also
thought that you
everything is hopeless and this is never
going to work i'm never gonna work this
out um you probably have
you know like i'm sure i had a bug five
years ago that i was like no
this is never i'm never gonna be smart
enough to fix this i have no idea why
this is happening
this is the worst i should have just
used unreal engine you know whatever
whatever it might be um and then if you
look back at that and then realize that
oh actually that wasn't too bad i solved
that like a few weeks later and sure it
was hard but i did it
then that will maybe inspire you to not
give up and
to finish this even though i i am i am
this close
to just completely giving up but anyway
so
yeah so we have this cool sky um don't
even need cube maps anymore
um so life is great no i'm kidding i do
i do have to solve that bug though
seriously but um
anyway let me know what you guys thought
of this little uh video i know this
wasn't really like anything that
um kind of dramatic um
but yeah we now support vulcan which is
pretty exciting if you want more
information about the shader pipeline
more information about
uh the sky that i added today um which
was like about an hour so it's probably
really raw and needs some love
um or like really anything else that's
new um
then let me know in the comment section
below because these devlogs like you
know i will make them on any topic i
feel like but i also want to
kind of talk about things that you guys
might be interested in
um and i know that i haven't even
covered things like shadows yet that i
said i would do in much more
uh in a much kind of more in-depth video
i guess so if there's something that you
want to see
please let me know otherwise thank you
guys for watching hope you enjoy the
video please don't forget to hit the
like button
also don't forget that you can go to
patreon.com to help support the
development of hazel and the game engine
series and
everything that i'm doing on my youtube
channel you also get access to this
like what you just saw here this is all
committed
and pushed and on get lab and ready for
you to
you know inspect and maybe even fix the
bug for me i
like the thing is seeing the engine at
this stage where it's already like you
know it's looking pretty cool
you know we've got like it almost it
almost looks like an engine now and it's
almost ready for me to actually start
creating stuff with it because that's
like
that's something that i honestly am so
excited about like i'm excited about
you know getting all of this kind of um
all of this kind of uh
you know uh i don't know i don't even
know what to call it all this kind of
you know first you know minimal vibe
product
you know vertical slice kind of stuff
done so that we have all the basic
features of what we need in a game
engine done so that we can actually
start creating content on that creating
games creating
you know scenes building stuff you know
all that kind of stuff and that's really
where all this is heading
um as well as obviously no you know the
educational side of it with the game
engine series but then also the content
creation side of it
which i'm going to start doing a lot
more videos about when hazel reaches
that point which hopefully will be maybe
by the end of this year or something
like that
we'll see but yeah making a game engine
is is definitely a lot of work but thank
you guys for watching thank you for all
your lovely support i don't think i
definitely would not be anywhere near
this level
if it wasn't for you guys um because uh
your support is really what keeps this
project happening so thank you so much
um for all of that i love you all and
i'll see you next time goodbye
yeah we're not gonna talk about the hair